Pasquale Harrison-Julien.
- En l'espace de quelques
heures, deux bombardements
ont fait deux morts et causé
des dommages considérables
dans la capitale de l'Ukraine.
Les cibles? Un immeuble
résidentiel et une usine
aéronautique.
Pour l'occasion, le maire
de Kiev est venu constater
les dégâts. L'ancien champion
de boxe craint une
intensification des attaques.
- La moitié des habitants
de Kiev ont quitté la capitale.
- La journaliste Tetyana
Ogardkova a quitté la capitale
pour s'installer dans le sud-
ouest du pays, à 450 km de là.
Son mari et son père
sont toujours à Kiev,
pour prêter main forte.
TETYANA OGARKOVA, journaliste
resp. département international
- Les routes sont barrées,
la circulation est difficile,
justement, à cause de "check
points" partout. Donc, la ville,
ce n'est plus la vie normale.
Ce n'est pas la vie d'avant.
C'est la ville un peu déserte,
en tout cas, à moitié déserte.
- Les combats se sont poursuivis
bien au-delà de la capitale.
Près du centre historique
de Kharkiv, dans l'est du pays,é
la cible des missiles. Deux
personnes y ont perdu la vie.
Et à Donetsk, les forces
séparatistes pro-russes ont
accusé l'Ukraine d'avoir visé
le centre-ville et d'avoir ainsi
tué au moins 16 personnes.
L'armée ukrainienne a fermement
rejeté l'accusation.
À Marioupol, des images de drone
captées par une unité de défense
nationale ukrainienne montrent
l'étendue des dommtststststs
à des quartiers résidentiels.
Des habitants à bord
de 160 voitures ont pu quitter
la ville assiégée en empruntant
un corridor humanitaire.
Par ailleurs, les autorités
sont revenues sur le tristement
célèbre bombardement d'un
hôpital pédiatrique la semaine
dernière pour confirmer le décès
de la femme qu'on apperçoit ici
sur une civière et celui
de son bébé qu'elle portai
Malgré la destruction e
morts, certains Ukrainiens
restent optimistes
et choisissent de rester
pour aider, comme ici, dans
la ville portuaire d
(chant)
Depuis bientôt deux semaines,
des résidents se relaient
pour remplir des sacs de sable
pour freiner éventuellement
l'arrivée des forces russes.
- Je dirais quand même que la
grande majorité des Ukrainiens,
plus de 90 %, croient que
l'Ukraine sortira vainqueur
de cette guerre, puisque
c'est une guerre absolument
inutile, absolument absurde.
- Si la majorité de la
e e e e e e est toujours
en Ukraine, l'ONU rapporte
aujourd'hui que ce sont plus
de 2,8 millions de personnest ts
le début de la guerre. Un flot
de réfugiés que l'Europe n'avait
pas connu depuis la Deuxièmeere.
Ici Pasquale Harrison-Julien,
R